the Amazon is burning in Brazil at a
record rate forest fires are raging in
the rainforest there have been nearly
73,000 fires this year already a more
than 80 percent increase compared to
last year environmental groups are
blaming right-wing president jarba
scenario they say he has loosened
environmental regulations and encouraged
loggers and farmers to clear the land
accelerating deforestation bolson arrow
has struck back claiming that NGOs might
be starting the fires themselves to make
him look bad he was pressed once again
today and again he cited no evidence do
you want me to blame the indigenous the
Martians there are strong suspicions
it's because the NGOs lost their funding
strong suspicions based on what there's
no proof nobody writes I'll set fire to
that if you don't catch someone
red-handed setting the fire then look
for those who ordered it it's a crime
could it be the farmers yes everyone is
a suspect but the biggest suspects are
the NGOs now the raging fires covered
Sao Paulo which is home to more than 12
million people under a blanket of smoke
so thick it blocked out the Sun we see
video here of how Brazil's biggest city
was plunged into darkness in the middle
of the day and there were also reports
of black rain in Sao Paulo a twitter
user posted a photo here of what she
says is a glass of rainwater and you can
see it looks more like something from a
dirty puddle let's get some analysis on
the story now we have Mallika Vera Sami
with us she's a researcher at Berlin's
Humboldt University she's an expert on
sustainability and conservation and
she's currently researching how to
prevent deforestation hi Malaika thank
you for joining us put this into context
for us how significant is the situation
that we're seeing on the ground in the
Amazon right now as you just pointed out
you know this is an 80% increase from
normal levels and I think the forest
fires are manifestations of the
governance level issues in Brazil right
now that's encouraging organized crime
and killing of indigenous people in 2008
18 we saw every week free indigenous
people that's every week being killed
for protecting their ancestral land so
so what that means is that these fires
have huge implications for biodiversity
and the people living in the forest I do
want to ask you more about the
governance but tell us what those
implications are first of all for
biodiversity why is this such an
important land as you know the amazon
basin is very rich in biodiversity and
has important forests climate feedbacks
ooh any impacts on the forest has
climate implications and and and and of
course biodiversity implications because
of its a rich hotspot for biodiversity
now wildfire now forest fires are rare
in the Amazon but in the during the dry
season people exploit the dry conditions
to set fires for forest clearing for
farmlands and cattle pasture so what you
get getting is that the current governor
governance situations and very warm
conditions in Brazil is encouraging more
people to set more organized crimes
especially for forest clearing so what
do you mean by organized crime who do
you say is behind us so there's a huge
land market in Brazil for clearing land
and legalizing this land these lands
forth for farming and cattle ranching so
the so I'm not talking about farmers and
of course some of the fight fires are
caused by farmers and selves but most
much of it is what you call guerrillas
the people who are looking for land to
convert into cattle ranching and
farmland this is a business as happening
in Brazil and the current governance
situation is encouraging that kind of
business model you keep saying the
current governance situation are you
pointing the finger directly at the
president jarba scenario
environmentalists say he has least
loosened the regulation environmental
right
Galatian can there really be a direct
link made between his policies and what
we're seeing I think I think there can
be a direct link I think he's
encouraging he is dismantling
environmental laws and he is and in
particular Lee he's undermining
indigenous rights because he knows that
indigenous people have been protecting
those forests so this double actions is
really dangerous for the Amazon right
now what can countries like Germany for
example do here to help the situation I
think I think recently we saw the
suspension of German aid to for the
environment and we clearly see that this
has no if it didn't work now didn't work
I think what we see is that the only
actions that can really work is to work
with the trade deal trade agreement now
the trade agreement between bridge
between the EU and the Mercosur country
clearly says that both parties need to
respect the United Nations Convention
for framework for climate change
clearly with everything that's happening
in Brazil even before the trade
agreement with all the things happening
the trade agreement was still signed and
now that we see the manifest the the
acceleration of the actions on the
ground the dismantling of environment
the laws and the and especially on
indigenous people we see that the trade
deal is even more dangerous so what we
are asking is for Angela Merkel to work
with EU government to block this this
trade deal and until governments like
Paulson eros government are able to show
commitments to the Paris agreement in
particularly to work to the rights of
indigenous people you talk about
economic pressure here just very very
briefly de árbol scenario says his
government doesn't have the resources to
fight these fires do you believe that no
because I think I think we saw in the
past that in pay the space agency have
done amazing work in fact we have seen
that nowhere in the world where they are
doing live monitoring of deforestation
and image
enforcement so this has happened in the
past I don't know what has changed right
now economically for buzzin arrow to say
that they don't have the resources to do
it
all right Malika Veeraswamy from
Berlin's Humboldt University thank you
so much for sharing your insights with
us today thank you so mean